we got a little debate club boys up
first we have Ashley Ashley from
Columbus sup guys hope you're having a
great day I'm coming to you from
Columbus Ohio with a debate club
question for you really quick I just
want to say that I met Brendon and Derek
at the Pittsburgh improv the other day
it was really nice meeting you both you
guys both killed it and you're both
really sweet and nice so I want to say
thanks for making my weekend so good no
problem already told Derek this but if
you guys decide to need a white girl for
culture corner which I think you do let
me know we had enough why no I'm just
doing Cleveland the other day and I was
really upset about it I ended up having
an exam that following day so I couldn't
be oh it's okay I'll be a memory so back
to the debate club question it's October
its quote-unquote spooky season so
here's your question are ghosts real or
are they not real personally I don't
know and I don't know if I want to know
the answer let me know what you guys
thinking thank you young lady for uh I'm
sorry that um you couldn't make it to my
show um is ghost real but she doesn't
know she wants to know the answer so I
don't know if I want to tell her yeah
tell her either I don't know she can
handle it dude one time my friend died
and uh and then that night I thought
that he was there and I never felt like
somebody was there like in your bed
no outside on the porch he's just
chilling us on the porch he was trying
to get in but he didn't have any hands
mmm now do you think it was a post mates
and you forgot about it no no no this
was before post mates about three years
before post mates is in a rural area
where post mates went out there
somebody's gonna probably gun them down
that's fair so you know I've post mates
huh how about those post mates they go
into the hood like SEAL Team six yeah
dude plug for a [ __ ] batch of taquito
deliver a hot pizza dodged some bullets
real Americans oh dude and by the time
you get there the pizza's just warm
cause of all the bullets in it
cheese a little shuffled up because he's
running so far uh-huh all right ghost
we'll listen I'll say this and this is
well documented I was on a ghost
adventure show with zak bagans mm-hmm
now I'm not positive we found that ghost
pretty sure we found it goes I was
scared shitless Oh shitless I was so
scared
hmm and ever since then I believe in
ghosts well I think ghosts have to be
real because I think there's something
you know a lot of times I feel a spirit
inside of me that is separate from my
body it's like my body is just kind of
like a bus and the spirit is like riding
around in this bus so I think if you die
then the spirit gets loose and then it
can some of them that can be around it
sometimes I can't I think some of that's
depending upon whether and some of
that's depending upon you know like rent
control all that kind of [ __ ] so you
probably I'm not gonna tell you anymore
I think no you don't can't handle it
yeah I don't think do you believe in
ghosts II not at all no do you believe
in afterlife yeah yeah you better
believe in a damn afterlife but you
don't believe in ghosts I don't think
people die then they hang out on earth
cutting light switches on why not this
maybe they work for a Cliquot maybe they
work for the power company if they're
ghosts yeah well they [ __ ] like turn
on lights and pushing over certain like
all they can do what if those are only
tricks do what you were a shitty David
blame that's all the ghost is oh my god
is a shitty David Blaine I'm a wiggle
this chain over here I'm a Duty's lights
I'm a [ __ ] touch you know Samuels
[ __ ] neck that's it brother Saul yeah
I put a whisper and bread in there at
night
like that's what I'm doing man you
believe in an afterlife but not go
something's got to happen what do you
mean nothing to light your [ __ ] out
Derek losing all of our black audience
by not believing in heaven and aren't
you a fan of the Kanye West album and
you don't think there's go sunday
service man is what I'm saying if Kanye
if you don't think Kanye's going to
heaven dude he's the [ __ ] black Tesla
brah okay Johnny is going to heaven
people out here milling around and [ __ ]
it I don't know if he is huh nice but
he's brave bro Kanye's brave and crazy
he's like brave e crazy cat what do you
think you guys have ghosts in your
community or something what's going on
you shouldn't have tons of go I could
see that because Asians never truly die
that's the thing Wow just I'm the ones
that started the whole ghost rumors no
these not a rumor yeah they did
you you believe in ghost cat yep but I
don't know if all races which is camera
as a ghost I could [ __ ] see you races
become ghosts no that's the thing I
think only some races then become ghosts
some of them just kind of go to heaven
or hell or maybe somewhere else
believe that I think all races go you
know already like a little Asian ghost I
think would be kind of cute you know hey
booboo that's a Latino goes a I'm from
Ecuador I'm hiding
I think papi yeah my ting overeater
apparently your ghost is super gay he's
not gay man
this is how we sound I have a wife
you heard him to that I just playing
just playing homeboy
I got 11 curing we're all goes there's a
chili in my ass what bro I have a wiping
jeez mundane you hear about my [ __ ] a
second ago bro you bros a different goes
up gay I can't be more obvious Homes
stuff my jalapeno chili uh-huh you're
not even game bro it's that guy throwing
like a tight suit man you might be right
bro you're not even a cop bro you're in
a [ __ ] van right now what well and
that's all right now I don't do improv
that's why I can't go so we got one out
of two believe in ghosts
well ghost here's tap believe in ghosts
Derek doesn't but he believes in Kanye
West is a
her life thought and you're kind of odd
believing ghost man goes yeah I grew up
in there's a lot of haunting a lot of
people haunted dude they had a guy who
impersonated a ghost in our town and he
haunted a Ramada and the police busted
him driving a Ford Ranger [ __ ] yeah dude
Dodge Ram now there's a lot of
witchcraft in New Orleans huh there's
some [ __ ] [ __ ] and armed [ __ ]
keeping it together
I'll admit that there's also just some
[ __ ] that have dreadlocks but just by
but this DeAndre Hopkins that you're
talking about dude oh you might be right
yeah that he got his arm caught in his
hair dude titty cap are you trying to
call me without interference
there's nothing feet long I'm all about
everybody having long hair dude I got it
but at a certain point well you kind of
got you got here come the second down
marker the other day kept on keepin on
bro but we had an assistant coach he
thought I had me kidnapped in his hair a
nutritionist brother finding her one of
his sideburns I'm just saying it's
getting intense DeAndre um but good luck
with ghost girl hopefully it works out
in you too what else you got we got 57%
went with ghosts are real
yep mmm that's fair have you ever seen
any ghost activity at the Comedy Store
Thea have you ever seen anything weird
go down there write some dark vibes
there I've seen a lot of people run the
light I've seen a lot of bad [ __ ]
comedy including some alone that wasn't
good so I've seen a lot of us I'll tell
you this you get haunted by some bad
sets I'll say that you're a bad set up
there that shouldn't want you that [ __ ]
will haunt you
[Music]
nothing
[Music]